hola
what's up everybody it's chrissy
candules christie coquito san juan
chrissy
i hope you guys enjoy
the best of hey babe we took a little
vacay enjoy the video may 3rd we got my
comedy special coming out on netflix
called specially weshy and it's going to
be glorious i'm going to go stick a
canepa up my ass
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey baby
[Music]
[Music]
hey babe look at this well we're doing
it we're doing it
so
you
have never had a pork chop never and
that's what this is here that is what it
is okay i've also never had goat cheese
just goat cheese on the plate and you
yes have never had a cinnabon
look at this
bang
we have a mild it's actually it's warm a
warm cinnabon okay which we were told by
the chef we said hey she said hey listen
stupid you told me not to eat this up
everybody said we've got to start the
show on the show the chef told us the
chef had an attitude if i'm being honest
now listen this is out of the this is an
authentic cinnabon it's just in tin foil
because we put it in the mic
authentic cinnabon from carvel on 86th
street in brooklyn shout out shut up um
so i'm gonna now take a bite for the
first time in my life yes of a pork chop
and goat cheese now let me ask you
something yeah because the chef first of
all the chef is unbelievable
phenomenal food yes
we think 800 calories on this whole
plate so i'm well within my room
we're guessing i wonder what the
calories are i don't know if you're
telling me though when i cut into this
yeah i won't there'll be no maggots and
when i eat it maggots won't explode in
my stomach from the larva from the pork
yeah right so how maggots are coming to
pass okay is flies turn into maggots
right so once flies go into your meat
and then they have sex with each other
they have babies the babies are maggots
something like that i'm not exactly sure
it's not gonna happen in the pork chop
cause that's what we said on the one
episode that's right everybody got mad
because we didn't know and they told us
maggots come from flies got it
okay
all right i'm gonna do this i'm so
excited for you because there's only one
first pork chop right now let me okay is
there a bone in here or is it there is a
bone but it plays like a steak you know
you can eat around the bone all right
let me down all right all right i'm like
genuinely yes get in there nice wow i
mean
hold on
okay here we go i mean first of all this
thing cuts like butter is that yeah
is this your favorite thing to eat so
wait i'm checking right now i love a
grilled pork chop it's unbelievable
what do you think about it there's a
nice char on that some nice spices right
nice and now you're saying that spice
that's not larvae that's nose that is
not gonna be a magnet maggots come from
flies they brought there when they bring
their breath they bring that extra
baggage with them just like jumping in
cold water like jumping in cold water
our father who are in heaven hal will be
in the name of the kingdom come then
we'll be done oh no this is never give
us a day
but deliver us from evil man
take your time you might have got some
fat on the edge
if i'm being a hundred percent honest
with you
i'm being this is genuine this is
genuinely i'm genuinely dead serious i'm
about to say right now
maybe the best thing i've ever eaten in
my entire life
i swear to god
that may be
like i almost feel like
i've been i've turned my back on an
entire
food
i've been trying to tell you it's just
so good this is like truly like butter
like
do they always do like that or is that
just the chef just understand there's
many different ways this is prepared a
certain way okay now i have to go insist
there's some
okay so now
can you eat raw pork is that okay to eat
okay so dude i gotta be honest with you
i mean
dude i i
isn't
it's good right
i mean
wow
you've been missing out
yeah i mean that's not really how
they're eating but you know it is what
it is you know
i mean
you got a little swatch here
yeah take care of it now get take give
me yours
oh my covered rag
that's one of the best things i've ever
eaten in my what's the sauce on what is
it is it just the pork is so good
pork is it
doesn't look appetizing but it is right
it's the rub is unbelievable isn't it
just a nice grilled pork i see how lean
the meat is
tender and tasty it's bursting with
taste
so how do they make bacon out of this
i don't know any of that stuff
it's a different part of the pig though
look at
you really made a mess
yeah so so what do you think now what do
you think
you could have been eating pork chops
this whole time
i regret i fully 1000 regret
not ever tasting a pork chop in my life
even if it is going to turn into maggots
and larvae which i still kind of am
convinced it is in my stomach i'll just
have a long day in the bathroom tomorrow
and i'll come back the next day and eat
a second pork chop
it's almost worth the maggots it's worth
the maggots now now the goat cheese is
next different different thing so this
you have it in a salad but maybe you
want to get in a nice chunk and just eat
it this is it's it's i got to be honest
with you this is grossing me out to have
to eat the goat cheese really the pork
chop was so appetizing and good this i
gotta be honest with you like i'm
skeeving this right a lot of people
don't just eat a chunk of goat cheese on
its own i you know you have it here
mixed into a salad you have some
complimentary flavors with it so should
i eat it with the salad do you think we
got i think both i think you eat it raw
first all right let's do it let's do it
[Music]
[Laughter]
no no
really you're having that bad reaction
you're gonna wash that down with pinot
grigio oh
i can't do it really really it's that
bad i can't what's in here apples i
can't do it
it's that no what are you doing oh
that's crazy you look barbaric
the ghost is just you you have to i
can't i can't look at you like this i'm
going to start drawing
i can't look at you i'm still driving i
need to go cheese you you have a whole
you have to wipe your mouth down and
wipe your
it's
hands
it's too much
no dude that the goat cheese
smell disgusting wait a second now i
sound like derosa hold on hold on
no if you went to rojo you would say
something outlandish like yeah
goat cheese is not available in 40
states
so i gotta be honest i think the goat
cheese is delicious
delicious it's just creamy
it's it's so good
the salad and the apples fantastic
the goat cheese literally dude i almost
threw up that goat
that was a real reaction i can't deal
with the goat cheese i never want to eat
goat cheese again i'm actually done with
goats are you serious i don't want to do
anything from goats anymore get yourself
an apple and a walnut on the fork and
have it with everything combined walnuts
is another thing i'm new to
i can't ever do the goat cheese again
i literally the goat
the goat cheese is a hard
it's the goat cheese is a hard no the
pork chop is i could probably eat i
would eat your pork chop if it was
cooked to the right temperature yeah
yeah mine you could die from a pork chop
was the best i'm i'm being dead serious
maybe that's why i think the goat cheese
is so bad because the pork chop was so
good so i was expecting to have balls
blown off again because the pork chop is
life changing and then the goat cheese
is reconfirming why i never had goat
cheese in my life i don't like goat
cheese you're blowing me away with your
disdain for the goat cheese i feel like
it's this creamy delicious elevated
elevating ingredient thinking about a
goat
just thinking about it
and the cheese is really i mean the
goats have they have cheap chin hair
yeah what you're doing now is you're
trying you're thinking of a goat as a
hole while you eat a salad
if this pork chop was growing out of the
side of a pig i'd eat it off the side of
a living pig right the goat cheese it's
it's it's a disgusting thing
it's i i never want to have the goat
cheese again but the but this the apple
salad
and whatever this is i mean compliments
to the chef this is the puree potato
puree i mean i feel like a newborn baby
right here i love the puree
the beret is good oh my gosh it's
outrageous i mean the chef i'm really
good
this puree is outrageous chef i love
this i love this
the puree i'm talking about the puree is
delicious i feel like an infant
wow i just got some goat cheese in the
puree
i gotta be honest i think he's being a
little over the top
because he's that
he's he's literally almost throwing up
wow i guess you know people don't like
it i guess he's one of those people
wow i i really don't know i know i know
you shouldn't be focusing on goats as a
whole when you eat it i think that's the
issue
you got water all over your limbs
go cheese
i'm going to look into the camera right
now and i'm going to tell you guys
exactly what i mean every word of this
i would rather be beheaded by isis than
never have to eat goat cheese again
don't put that out there
bring it on i would honestly if honestly
the situation he described i'm just call
me what you will i'd rather have goat
cheese literally if you ever had me in a
hostage situation where i had government
secrets the uh you i would give them up
in a second if the if the interrogator
just put a little bit of goat cheese on
my lip if he just had a little spoon and
said tell me everything i'd say no no
what if you have to let go cheese like
off of a goat cheese off a goat's like
beard like you put the goat cheese on
the goat and you just said go right up
to the goat no no i'd rather
i'd rather
yeah
what if it was called are you getting
thrown off by the words goat and cheese
put together and it's goat what if it
was called something like special cream
or something i don't know
well just like uh you know whatever it
is it had its own big goat i think go me
thinking of a
goat it's making me don't make that face
i swear to god because i'm that guy i'm
the guy i have a weak constitution
so you ever see that scene from stand by
me when somebody throws up and somebody
else throws up and they're only in
blueberry pies and then everyone's
throwing up
you just did a dry heave and everything
in me i felt about to dry heave myself
well it's one of those things where the
goat cheese was so disgusting to me i
immediately felt it in my butt you ever
get like a chill when you feel it right
in your butthole i felt the goat cheese
right in my butthole immediately right
where the pork chop i fell to my penis
which is a different feeling it's one's
good one's bad where do you feel the
pinot grish the pinot gris baby you got
goat cheese all over your wine i can't
do it i can't do it you ate it's so
sloppy there's like remnants of goat
cheese everywhere i'm just gonna have to
do this
you're going to have to finish that
entire bottle
fine
don't go near an end to history we do
see what i really have to say at
patreon.com
[Laughter]
pork chop is is a delightful delectable
treat that you've been missing out on
it's one of those things where like
again trying to like you know
you know cut calories and not eat bread
i was always like all i can ever really
eat is salmon and chicken because i
don't really eat too much red meat i'm
like salmon chicken now i'm gonna eat
this it's lean now pork chop if i see if
i see a pork chop the only thing is
because the chef is such a great chef
the only thing that i'm considering
is maybe
the chef did you know some tricks of the
trade right and made the pork chop taste
even better and if i go and order it
from a restaurant it won't have the
chef's touch it's because
you're gonna have to take it that's
amazing the goat cheese though can go
for itself all right
i'm done with sal i'm done with goats
wow no dude that's wild if you ever made
me go cheese again i swear to god i put
every corner of every pillow directly at
you
[Laughter]
it'd be like a laser beam of pillows
corners
anywhere near you don't do it i don't if
we go to a petting zoo i'm skipping the
goats i i can't believe it what do you
what are you watching i don't know goat
cheese
goat cheese is disgusting wow wow
yeah i'm not a goat cheese person and
goats themselves are kind of like
satanic to me yes maybe that's what it
is they're a satanic animal i feel like
i'm eating the cheese of satan
[Laughter]
eight years old ian brackenberry chanel
wow
channel
wow interesting did i show you my ring
[Laughter]
it's like a buck it brings me so much
joy
he just crazy
that is legit the same tupperware i give
my five-year-old daughter for school
every day what are you saying i say it
again tupperware say it again slow
tupperware slow very slow first say the
first syllable
tub
wrong
what do you mean wrong i thought i
caught that you're throwing away you're
throwing bees at me
peas babe
what are you talking about tupperware
tupper it's chopper it's tupper babe it
always has been always will be
yeah did you know that pimped it was
tupper i thought it was tubberware
because it kind of looks like a tub
you know
that makes total sense so you're saying
my whole life i have a clinical
doctorate degree in physical therapy
i've been walking up to people yeah and
saying do you have tub or whatever can i
take that home with some tubberware yeah
tubber yeah which this is mind-blowing
if you haven't seen the previous
episodes we talked about i never had
goat cheese or a pork chop which we
thought was crazy even crazier to me
sal has never in his life he grew up in
the united states of america has never
had a cinnabon no
it's not like you grew up in uzbekistan
you grew up in the united states of
america in the state of new york the
metropolis of potentially the world you
never had a cinnabon you never had a
city no i don't have any and i can't
believe that that's a bit as big a deal
as you're making it is it really i mean
what's the bigger deal pimp what do you
think the bigger deal is me not having
pork chop or goat cheese or or cinnabon
well you should tweet this out we're on
taste buds
[Laughter]
but a pork chop is from it's a dish
that's been around for thousands of
years since the ancient samurai right
but uh cinnabon is like uh you know the
last 20 30 years so it's like i feel
like it's crazier that you haven't had a
pork chop what do you think
what do you think pimp knowing that you
dabble in marijuana i'm very surprised
you haven't had a cinnabon i know but
also dabbles in cbd
promo code hey babe that's what it is
and here we go all right so here we go
so
cut it well yeah you want to cut it yeah
or
cut it well um i think the chef gave us
uh
oh she here she chef gave us a cinnabon
knife
yeah
boom
now by the way keep in mind six dry one
cinnabon 880 cows babe
one city 880 no yes
oh my god how do you what do you do i
mean you just gotta go you gotta just
you gotta log out of your myfitnesspal
it's like eating a big mac or something
it's what it is okay okay you ready yeah
here let's see here here pull pull your
side
okay oh wow it's dense yeah it's dead
and the thing is it gets layers upon
layers so you see it opens up like an
onion the cinnabon's like a like a
manufactured onion when you eat an ants
there's more goo more cinnamon so this
isn't goat cheese this is cinnagoo
frosting then the inside it's like it's
like a strudel it's it's um it's the
best i think thing that an american's
ever made and i'm not sure if it's made
in america you you but this is this is
bad for you look at that look at on the
bottom
yeah yeah look at that there's all sorts
of uh caramelization going on there you
got yourself a nice cream yeah layers
okay
i could smell it i don't know i could i
get i can guess by the smell what this
is gonna taste like i've had pastry
before i've had cinnamon i've had icing
but but you never had you've never had
it all together you've never had a man
you've never had a united states
chemical induced cinnabon absolutely not
yeah let's do it all right
oh my god
oh my god
you've never had anything like that
style be honest with me
wow never had anything like that wow i'm
getting waves of flavor
i mean that cinnamon it almost feels
like there was a stick of big red yeah
you're also going to get waves of
feeling lightheaded because your sugar
is through the roof yeah i mean that
icing what is that dude it's not goat
cheese
oh my god the icing is outrageous let me
see
whoa
wow wow wow
this must sound good over the airwaves
um
so this is like that amsr stuff right oh
yeah
just just it's sitting up on that is it
am i getting that right amsr cinnabon
wow
i mean
there's something going on in there
that's not going on at a glance
like something in the middle there
that's happening it gets to be a gooey
treat that really comes together a
little thing the spanish call asuka
baby yeah they're finding ways to load
more and more sugar into that puppy wow
the cinnabon the goo a fresh
hot cinnabon at the airport i don't care
if the plane crashed i'd be happy yeah i
can imagine it coming right out of the
oven but you can't you i think if you
eat one of these alone your whole day
has to be rerouted
if you start your day off with one of
those you can't eat again until the next
week you're gonna you can't have one of
these how often can you have a cinnabon
no i mean
that okay i'll be honest with you i used
to when i was christy cinnabun's called
oh yeah you ate your cinnabon oh it's
gone your whole half is gone sal i could
have eaten
two cinnabons by the time you ate a
house wow no i love cinnabons the
cinnabon cereal fantastic
so the cinnabon um um uh
it's it's one of those things where it's
so good and and it's got so many
calories like i think eight or nine
hundred in one cinnabon
that you just have to kind of accept
accept it yeah it's like it's we're
doing it we're doing it yeah and you let
go cinnabon is good for a person who's
wants who says to themselves i'm gonna
start to get back in shape and go back
to the gym when i hit rock bottom if you
want to go quickly to rock bottom with
your weight cinnabon's the answer what's
the most have you ever had more than one
cinnabon sal are you kidding me oh my
god really really my cholesterol is 270
my blood pressure's 170 over 110. i used
to be 250 pounds babe have i had one
cinnabon you ready for about to tell you
no yes
what my dad what i used to do come on
dude not daily but what i've done
many times in my life is on the same
sitting gotten two cinnabons from the
carvel on 86th street and then walked up
two three blocks to nono's pizza and got
an entire zucchini slice pie and i've
eaten five or six zucchini slices back
to back wash them down with two
cinnabons and they also have here's the
other thing i got you a big cinnabun
they also have the mini cinnabon packs
and they also have cinnamon bun just the
inside of it like cinnamon bun rolls
with dip with the little icy frosting
dip i didn't even get you extra icing
normally what i do is i'll take a bite
of a cinnabon and i'll do a shot of the
frosting no
so for the first time since 2013 yeah
yeah and just a quick refresher if you
didn't see that a podcast i had a fish i
didn't want a fish uh it was brought
home by by my niece she won at a school
fair and the fish she won before that
always died and i had enough of it so i
spent the 30 40 50 to get the tank with
the filter and i threw this five cent
fish they call a feeder fish into a
thing i own i had it for six years right
it grew like that big it knew me we
found out it knew me i used to feed it
out of my hand i could put my fingers
like this it would swim through my
fingers the thing loved me loved you and
that's why i wanted to give it its
proper burial and by the way i have two
fish coffins in there
because what i think we want to do is
people started sending me coffins for
the fish and i think that we should
we'll reveal this fish train i'm
actually nervous because i don't want to
disrespect the body yeah or desecrate it
i don't know what we're about to see it
might be legit fish bones i don't know
it might have fully descended i wonder
if it retained its color i'm actually a
little bit sad now that i'm talking
about it you want me to do it then i i
just i don't know if the tindal is going
to stick to it this is my friend you
gotta understand for six years it really
was a pal of mine and a friend and it's
been dead for eight years so i'm about
to we're basically exhuming
a body of a dead friend of mine from
eight years ago
and if it really took uh if it really
took like a couple left turns in
albuquerque and it looks discolored and
i'm gonna feel very sad you might there
might be tonight when you put your head
on the pillow the ghost of the fish yeah
for right now but we're gonna do it
because it's hey babe and that's what we
do here it's hey babe and we're gonna do
it because because it's it's hey babe
and at this moment what you're doing is
hey brave
brave what you're about to do hey brad
so this is for i i have had so many
opportunities not great so far i'll be
honest with you so many opportunities to
do this and i didn't do it the fish is
in here we're going to open it but the
idea i think that we want to do as long
as we get through this portion
is we want to hold a full funeral full
funeral on patreon on patreon which by
the way our patreon is going to come
soon it's coming soon within the next
couple of weeks or i don't want to say
give it a time the patreon is coming
soon and there will be a funeral
for five cent fish yes that we will do
his name is fish live on patreon so but
right now on hay bay without any further
ado eight years in the making we are
finally going to unveil the dead
body of salsfish
do you want me to do it or can you do it
can you do it i don't know man i don't
want to help part of me is very nervous
right now okay
oh god i'm sorry fish okay okay
all right
all right all right
i'm nervous
oh my god i'm nervous don't don't wait
don't like don't like them up you know
it's right here
oh my god oh my god
oh i'm nervous i'm nervous right i'm
nervous
i'm nervous
are you nervous i'm you're not nervous
not really you don't have a relationship
with him if i'm going to be honest with
you 15 years ago i met this fish if you
if i'm gonna be 100 honest with you even
though i'm sensitive god you know i love
you i i i don't give a [ __ ] about you
you don't give a [ __ ] about it right now
because we're two different camps yeah
if it were okay about this fish why
would you i don't expect you to i don't
know what i want to let you know this
fish gave me a lot of good ideas i gotta
be honest with you i ordered fish for
lunch yeah so yeah
and then so disrespect to you with the
fish i'm just nervous
you should do it i have the last time i
saw him you gotta remember he was you
know floating dead in a tank yeah that
is true but he was like moments of that
he was alive right remember he died
suddenly i know you guys know this i
cleaned the tank and came back as i
always did i suddenly i thought someone
maybe murdered him possibly i don't know
culvert
if so he was out of his time that way
ahead of his time
oh god dude
oh i got a lighthouse are you all right
i already got lightheaded again i have
to go to the doctor right away okay i
think i saw a little what color was that
hold on it was a
yeah it's not gold
no it was a different color man
you ready oh i'm not ready chris i'm
actually not ready i'm actually not
ready i saw the tail and it freaked me
out big time
all right i'm gonna do it but i'm really
not ready i saw the tail and i'd send
shivers through my whole do you want me
to do it then do you want i'm also
afraid it's thawing and i don't want
that to happen it doesn't smell great
you ready oh chris oh go slow go slow
slow go slow because god forbid the
tinfoil attached to his body
oh it's disgusting
attached to its body oh the tin foil
attached to its body
oh god it looks like hibachi
[Music]
uh what are you gonna do do it gently
please okay okay
all right
oh god fish i'm so sorry fish
okay
okay oh that is weird for me
it's really weird you try to get the
tinfoil off touch its body maybe you
flip him the other way i don't want to
see his eyes though do you want to see
his eyes
do you want to see his eyes yes i would
oh
all right
oh it feels wrong
it feels wrong here it is and there's
his eye
oh my god i'm so sorry buddy i had the
best intentions it looks like here's
what it looks like i've got to be honest
with you just is the way it it came out
i'm sorry to say it style it looks like
a dead it looks like a conspiracy
theorist it's got a tin foil hat on
oh i'm so sorry there it is sal i'm so
sorry oh my god his eyes his eyes are
gone
his eyes are gone that's not that's his
eyeball sockets but it's not balls you
think your mother ate his eyeball oh
that poor fish
wow there it is
just look at it sal
that's the way to get past it oh my god
eight years i haven't seen this thing
oh i'm so sorry
funeral coming
soon great episode of hey babe if you
want to catch me doing stand up in your
city go to christycomedy.com
we got uh atlantic city new jersey
phoenix and red bank the vogel christy
comey.com i've also started my own
podcast called chrissy chaos go to
patreon.com christy comedy for all the
fun there
i don't know what to do
i don't know what to do
well i think what we have to do is end
the episode
um and uh i'm
uh yeah
oh man this is it's gonna be hard to do
plugs with the fish right there well i
mean listen but we gotta do it i mean we
got season nine of a practical joke is
starts february four thursdays 10 p.m on
true tv yes um
it's it's one of the bits we're having
today it's just today so it's today
today's thursday um
oh god it feels weird misery index is on
tuesday nights 10 30 on tbs uh season
three just started
and then uh i'd like to get into this
another time i'll explain it but this
feels really weird man i am on i'm on an
app called community where you could
text me directly and i've been enjoying
it it doesn't mean i'm to text you back
i can't text back everybody but i do get
your your texts and uh
so it's important you do this
if you want to uh text me on the
community app um i try to answer like 50
a day and i also drop
information there before i drop it on
any other social media because i think
it's like a special thing that i want to
share with you guys that my number is
718-260-6619 if you want to text me
any advice or condolences about to fish
or
if you'd like to suggest what you'd like
to see at the funeral procession on
patreon for the fish um
savalcanocomedy.com
um for for dates and for the dates yeah
and i guess you know this is us just you
know
hey babe
this has been hey babe
so
this has been hey babe
for this world's big escape
[Applause]
[Music]
look at that now guinness book
guinness book record holder a female
with the world's biggest mouth world's
biggest mouth uh should we sit here in
the middle yeah let's hit her in the
middle would you i was gonna say again
stan
so hi samantha so first of all where are
you from hi i'm from stanford
connecticut okay shout out to stanford
connecticut yeah oh here could you sit
in the middle yeah sit there oh yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
get it nice and get you know you're in
here okay
i got here and you were in the back
green room with us and i walked up to
you and i said i have a million
questions and i'm gonna wait until i get
onto the stage when did you know when
did you know you had a big mouth
since i could look in the mirror pretty
much yeah now does anybody else in your
family have a big mouth or is it just
you it's just me so i have i have family
members with big smiles
but
yeah i don't know something got
yeah so that just is uh just
it's just it's just it's like no
you don't have any
yeah
so you don't have like a great answer no
okay not that i know of okay um yeah it
was just a natural phenomenon you know
and you know to be honest sitting here
very close to it does feel it's it feels
like it's it's nice it's it you know
you're a very pretty girl but it does
feel a little bit like um there's a
gravitational pull in your mouth
i feel
like it's it's got a little bit of its
own energy because you're looking at me
but it's like a black hole don't you
feel a little bit god yes whoa
whoa
i stand right into the mouth of the
velvet of her of you yeah i don't know i
wasn't expecting you to do that when you
opened i've never been that close to
greatness before could you imagine could
you imagine like your first day as a
dentist and she's your first patient she
says open up you're like no you're
probably a dentist's dream oh my god
i mean they could probably just get in
there without even any trying to fight
over me i have dentists that reach out
and ask if they can fly me to their
dentist office like in florida like all
around i want to work on you you're
royalty but it's a lot of work you're
like you're an extra worker you're like
an only fans for dentists
that your teeth are exceptional
beautiful teeth it would be it would be
just a curse if you had the world's
biggest mouth but the most jacked up
teeth well i had an underbite when i was
little okay so yeah there's been no
surgical intervention there's been no
surgical intervention now nice yeah on
that journal
yeah i just have so many one of you one
for one yes yes so my question is when
you were a kid let's say you're in third
fourth grade where like you know people
like would they throw things in your
mouth where they yeah what what what
would the kind of kids like because i
would imagine if you were in my class i
would say you know we gotta like you
know i tried to put number two pencils
in or yeah throw things in the mouth or
if i if i was smoking a cigarette in
high school my mom's gonna like oh [ __ ]
you know throw it yeah you know yeah
totally yeah if you ever get pulled over
by the cops you just put every single
thing in the car yeah i just shove it
all the way in your mouth yeah
registration please
reach down in did they celebrate you in
in in grammar school did you did you
have a hard time no no no no no no no no
no no no it was a rough it was a rough
growing at it you know yeah but what did
people what would the kids tease you
about like would anybody try to put
anything in your mouth or well it was a
lot of like big mouth bass like people
threw water on me because they said i
was a fish and i should get back in the
ocean because like
well if you do
that you're doing an amazing fish
impression i don't think of a i don't
think of uh of a fish is having a big
mouth no i don't either
i think of their cheeks actually going
in and having a small mouth well they've
heard nobody now what do you because
this is the kid who we originally talked
about this is the boy with the world's
biggest mouth have you ever met him so
turns out he's 16.
and he like lives in minneapolis so i
felt weird being like like messaging
like an underage kid being like you want
to do some health stuff together
hey you want to shove some stuff in our
mouths together so i felt a little weird
but um i would let you know i think that
would be some good content yes some good
yeah are you guys going to have
eventually when he's legal 18 when he's
legal well i even said you know i'm like
hey if your mom wants you even guardian
yoshi hang out
oh my god yeah yeah he's like okay
yeah because it's interesting
and so you actually though have the work
you have the guinness
book of world records for the female
biggest yes but technically
i don't know if you met my ex
okay
um like it wasn't a sexual joke it was
like she has a big mouth like she's
mouthing all right let's all just forget
that one
edit that out um but it was you know i
have a wider mouth technically fourteen
and a half centimeters
wow wide now how much is that in inches
it's like eight
eight inch back checkers
yeah eight eight inch mouth about an
eight inch yeah six seven
so did you call them or did they hear
about you and contact you how does word
get out about it so i say it was the
tick tock children of america okay you
know it was really my tick tockers if
anyone's a tick talker out
newly crowned new within two weeks oh do
you know who whose crown you took
i don't know some
amateur yeah
yeah yeah if you're watching and we know
that you are yeah
[Laughter]
no more imagine having the world's
second biggest mouth i know
i mean that's such a downer you got to
walk around being like you see this it's
progressive right it's not the biggest
myth runner up yeah what about eating
competitions like would would you be
good in like a hot dog like could you
take down joey chestnut well so i've
actually dueted some of his videos and
obviously i can't eat as much as he can
but i can eat pretty fast so like i
would say like i would love to go up to
him like a who can eat a hot dog the
fastest like one hot dog yeah you know
what i mean yeah because yeah because i
mean i would think you could well i can
shove it shove it down there pretty get
it right down yeah yeah yeah right
well
let's just let's just all think it
together and not say anything the fan
wants to know yeah
this is a pg show hey my daughter's here
come up here
in my mouth she's asking
yes please just shut up when you stretch
out your mouth does it hurt
yeah
it does not hurt no it's like my muscles
in my face are jacked yeah
like yeah you're jacked overall jacked
yeah yeah you know yeah you gotta watch
out on the streets how do they measure
the mouth
caliper oh there's a video there's a
video somewhere where they're like it's
like a digital it's like a construction
so
you didn't know when they came to you if
you were gonna beat the person
it was a thing they did but they might
have measured you and been like sorry
you didn't make it totally oh so were
you nervous a little but i was you
wanted the title right i mean i felt
pretty good i felt pretty good going in
and you had to just expand your mouth as
much as you can yeah you have to do it
five times in a row
by a dentist by like a certified
professional
and the average of the five times and
you have to do obviously
top to bottom and
side to side and i just came to your
house and did that no we had to go to a
dentist's office i had to do a whole
thing we had to get witnesses we had to
get witness statements we had to get i
had to get blood work i had to get i had
to prove i'm not on any medication that
would make my mouth stretch
like it's crazy it's very strict it's so
interesting do you have like a plaque or
something i do i should have brought it
i should have brought it yeah so what's
next for you what's next for the for the
mouth
well um you know movies are we doing
movies or it's like yeah maybe like a
scary movie like you do that i would you
know i you know i do like to do some if
you're on my tech talk i do like to do
some some jokes once in a while oh yeah
yeah um you said you sing right right
yeah you sing
can you sing a little bit
yeah anybody want to hear sam saying can
you sing um
would you like to sing the national
anthem oh can you sing uh big mouths by
morrissey
what's the song you like to sing um
i don't know anyone else anyone get a
song like a big mouth what's like a
stephen tyler well you know
oh he's got a big [ __ ] mouth
yeah yeah that's bon jovi right
yeah i see a little silhouette of a man
you know what i mean yeah yeah you know
yeah yeah yeah that was queen no but no
no
you start you teased us i want to hear
you belt it out what can we what song is
good yeah how about what do you know
what do you know like a nice ballad what
about my neck show you the world oh i
can't show you the world do you know
that one i don't know let it go i don't
know yeah oh yeah yeah yeah whatever you
want
let it go
let it go
can't hold it back anymore
let it go
let it go
wow
[Music]
oh speaking of singing cargo trains
coming through that's it there we go
this [ __ ] is bananas h-e-y-b-a-b-e
this [ __ ] is bananas h-t-y-b-a-b-e
this [ __ ] is bananas h-e-y-b-a-b-e
this [ __ ] is bananas h-e-y-p-a-b-e
we can stop now but it's gonna go by for
another three minutes yeah
this is good
this is good six o'clock shows are good
yeah this is six o'clock 100 degrees
that's all i'm doing for that's what it
is
yeah that's all i ever want to do from
now
do you think you could fit the train in
your mouth probably
check out the trail tracks and see
what are you gonna do one day when your
jaw breaks accidentally
never i will never break my jaw i'm a
professional you know i train i stretch
do you do
mouth and now that you have the title do
you like keeping yourself insurance yeah
i mean she's injured
no you're not
um do you ever worry about this 16 year
old [ __ ] from minnesota taking your
title yeah this little [ __ ] what is
this little bitch's name
isaac little [ __ ] his name's isaac yeah
isaac if you're watching you know and we
know isaac's watching right now because
you got someone gunning for can your
mouth grow any further
can you i don't know i feel like maybe
my mouth can get stronger like maybe you
know
yeah you know i could hold more okay i
don't know
and you know the opportunities are
endless
and you're proud of it you're proud
yeah like you know embrace what makes
you different you know you should
embrace what makes sense
right [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're gonna live forever
absolutely
okay well speaking of that so you've
brought some i brought some tricks to
put into your mouth so we'd like to see
that we thought for the live babe babe
she could put some tricks in her mouth
yep um
so i brought a little you know a couple
tricks for you guys i figured i don't
know if you guys want to participate and
be involved in the activities i'm trying
to put something in my mouth yeah it
would be the first time today yeah
all right so my one of my classics is
some donuts okay um but i also have you
know maybe we start out we warm up with
a lemon
you want to put a lemon in our yeah yeah
oh yeah we could try that oh i'm not
gonna
okay
okay all right so so
so are we doing it sideways i don't know
right in right like this long ways
holy holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
no i'm going to church i'm seriously
going to try this for you okay
i might could i can i oh my god
it's the whole thing's in her mouth holy
[ __ ]
uh is there anything realizing by the
way by even just trying to do this
there's no way i could be gay
is it
is there any scenario where this gets
lodged and literally blocks my past no
it legitimately
i know the heimlich it legitimately
hurts my jaw to even try to do this just
try to open your mouth as you've never
tried
it it hurts
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god that's pretty good
that's great
i am very important [ __ ] you isaac yes
that was really impressive all right
okay that's a lot all right so the next
step wow should we just put this yeah
just throw it in the back yeah yeah yeah
all right [ __ ] over i mean i bit that
yeah it's fine
whatever okay without cheating okay here
you go
an apple
all right let's get an apple in on now
all right ready yeah
oh my god the way you do it is like it's
oh my god be careful with yourself
no there's no give on the apple hi the
lemon had a little give there's no give
on this that you know apples
you know apples
how many of you have heard of an apple
how many of you want to shout
corrections at me about apples
i can't do it
it hurts my jaw all right
it really does hurt how about this
okay okay so we have a bag of carrots
what is this
um so
14 and a half centimeters wide and about
like eight centimeters top to bottom
chris and sally are they island babies
hey i said chris and saul you're island
babies without them boys yeah stop
already playing yo
hey chris inside there's some adam
babies keep my chin flowing with my
vision with my grandma man better keep
that gun hey chris and sal y'all so
dummy i'll be right in keep a wag one
staring at the sun i'll be sun gazing
and we'll be putting up like we super
saiyan
there's some island baby y'all already
know hey shout out chris d and sal
appreciate it you got to hear from a
shout out from the island boys it's
official and keep dancing alone man yes
yep and pop bottom give me a island boy
give me a hey baby
give me an island boy
give me a hey baby boy
give me an island boy
hey babe what's up babe what's up baby
baby i just at this point people know
what island boy is right because i just
saw it for the first time well it's
actually nice to see someone who hasn't
heard of island boy yet because it's
literally taking over
when did you hear about this for the
first time
i would say four days ago oh sorry
something like that i mean i heard about
it it went i'm living underneath
i think the tick tock might be at like a
billion views it's insane a billion it
might whatever it is because people
don't understand what they're looking at
well have we identified these kids no
i'm sorry no no babe do whatever you got
to do for yourself um um
we haven't identified them where are
they from
has anyone interviewed them florida we
know that they're from florida
do they have their own tick tock channel
or is this why soldier is their youtube
channel um but now everyone's just now
everyone's just kind of redoing the
island boy i mean everybody's talking
about the island boys they're trying to
get on the podcast the island boys are
going to be on bar stool today or oh my
god last week whatever so and these are
just two kids just two kids that they
won crate but this camp this is the
official music video it's only got 370
000 views no way well this is before
they went big this is from september
oh so so they put it out there and it
didn't pop until a couple of days ago
they were just like you open micros who
eventually eventually yeah directed by
at pete shot look at these kids jesus
let me pause that for one sec pimp
where do you think it went wrong for
them
at home
at home right at home i would say
i think what do you think came first the
teeth the tats or the hair
i think the taps probably came first
yeah i think so too because that hair
has to come dead last yes that hair
can't lead the pack that's like you
can't walk out regular with that hair no
no no no no it's like what's that crusty
car see the clown is there
is it a form of dreadlocks i guess
are they from an island no allegedly
they're from florida i don't think i
think they're probably how what do they
have on instagram now
235k all right i'm still beating them is
this
is this them
speaking this way or is this their
normal speaking voice no i think that's
them putting on a dialect they're
claiming i think we might have a
hilarious baldwin situation on our hands
where they're now coming out and
claiming their cuban but they probably
are just white kids okay that just are
have lost their minds y'all girl bro man
stop playing to tap in and message him
to see what he about man love he show
support man yeah
see i understood more of the island boys
song than that i don't think i
understood one word what do you think
the oldest person uh alive is right now
that has had actual enjoyable
intercourse
google it pimp i mean does someone keep
that stat the oldest person alive right
now by the way is kane tanaka at 118
years 152 days but lucille ramdan is
right there at 117 years 112 days so
she's coming right up that ass game
lucille could take it
if kane
drops and lucille lasts another year
yeah i love the name lucy and then back
to back latino tanaka
wait 118 is
118 years
all right you live to 90
fair game like pretty full life 90.
imagine living 28 years past 90. i mean
she looks exactly what i thought she
would look like barely that's kane
barely alive she just has a has a her
face is just stuck in a in an open mouth
like i'm in
every second of the day god bless this
god bless kane tanaka which sounds like
a great wrestler's name yeah the old
japan's kane tanaka
118
which means she was born about 1903
very good with the man 1903 wow
wow
she's
but she's a she's a global oh my god do
you know she's she's a global
literally universal
treasure
she's the oldest living she's a relic
she's a living relic every single person
out of the 8 billion on this planet
she's older than 8 billion people the
odds of that she was already 41
years old when world war ii ended
[Laughter]
she was 41 she was in her 40s when ww2
ended wait wait wait wait wait wait yeah
how old are you
36 okay if i'm doing quick math
[Laughter]
she was she was 80
hold on 30 you're 36 36 or 18 gets you
back to 18 gets her to 100 you minus
that she was 82 when you were born when
i was born she was already 82
82 when you were born she's still alive
right now wow
be covered i mean if she like every
little thing you think she'd be too
pandemic she'd be she'd be the spanish
flu she beat everything everything she
beat aids i pushed she beat everything
how did she not get aids her up against
the grizzly right now see what happens
see what happens
kane tanaka vs grizzly that's on the
patreon
it actually sounds like like like a
mortal kombat uh match-up let me ask you
tanaka first grizzly bear here's the
simple question what would you rather
watch logan paul mayweather or kane
tanaka versus grizzly tanaka versus
everyone you know they had those
t-shirts like cleveland versus the world
yeah or detroit versus everybody kane
tanaka versus everyone that's the merch
i want that shirt i want that shirt can
you give me another versus everyone
we're gonna do it kane tanaka should be
like our like mascot yes like the most
resilient human being on the planet
stands a test of time yes nobody
everybody bowed down to kane tonight
tanaka are we gonna get kane to knock on
the podcast or what oh my god only on
the patreon only on the page billion
dollar level one came to a million
dollars if you want to see us uh
interview king tanaka on the patreon how
about this on the patreon and when we do
lose cain tanaka we will do a live
stream at the funeral just like we're
gonna do a live stream in the funeral
for the fish that's right
wow
oh my god what does she do she said she
had pancreatic cancer at 45.
oh my god the number one death sentence
of cancers she had it at 45. she also
had colorectal cancer at
15 years ago
15 years ago what what is this
parativoid fever
that killed blackbeard oh my god
wait she she would love like to live to
the age 120. okay
i mean come on kane don't push it yeah
and obviously crediting family
sleep
hope
eating well and practicing mathematics
which i've actually heard keeps you
sharp up top mathematics yes i'm very
bad at math what does she eat every day
that she's 100 that she's so she's got
to be sush just sushi yeah but what
about the mercury
i don't think she i don't
yeah what is she she's also adopted kids
oh the couple worked in the store
selling shiroko and udon noodles uranus
are very good
she was alive before the car one of her
kids got captured at the end of world
war ii before flight
right
yeah i don't know i don't remember but
it's got to be before flight 1903. the
yankees hadn't won any championships yet
they weren't even a team
they were the highlanders
what what
canada wasn't even a country
damn well maybe they were
she was 20 in the roaring 20s yeah
that's perfect she's lived through
multiple depressions
yeah
she was apparently now here you are
complaining about seasonal allergies
yeah play some yeah complain about
seasonal allergies and kane tanaka says
what that's nothing
someone's got to be with her 24 7. now
got to be 24 7. i mean look at she what
just the sweetest
she's just such a sweet woman looks like
wow
she's got the guinness book of world
records now is that a title you guys
would really want to hold oldest person
alive you know what happens as you get
older too your teardrops dry out so she
looked like she was getting emotional
but she won't produce tears is that
that's a true story you tear your tear
ducts dry out as you get older very old
people that can't cry they're they they
just have no tear they have the emotion
is there in the brain but the tear ducts
are dried out can i ask you a question
how do you know this
where did you learn that fact i never
heard that in my entire life
now that you're questioning me on it i
could have made it up okay
just in your
best part awakening
it's folger's in your car by men
right there you go that's what it is
there you go juicy fruit is gonna move
yeah you know that one eight seven seven
six four three four four four four four
five eight what is that seven seven what
is that three four four one eight
hundred m a t t
there it is
are those local new york things give me
a break give me a break how about that
one for the new york state lottery i'm
yolanda
can i can you hand me can you can you
hand me that right there check this out
guys
we spoke about yolanda vega who is our
new york state lottery affiliate person
who draws the numbers we spoke about her
on a podcast that is unreleased as of
yet and might come out later but she is
our
basically our muse
and we love this woman
on the podcast would be a great get we
want to get yolanda vega on this podcast
we'd like to maybe she could even do if
you're friends with your family with her
we'd love to get yolanda on yes if
you're a friend or family member of
yolanda vega this and if you don't know
her since i'm a young person uh this is
the woman who draws the new york state
lottery numbers and she has a little
calling card and this is what she says
are you ready for this
do you think i love you too do you think
that she came up with that or you think
like she was just on the air one day oh
i saw a parent's name
[Laughter]
uh no i think that she probably just i
don't know like she's a broadcaster in a
sense right she just did it so i'm
yolanda vega if you're from new york
there is nothing that says new york as a
bodega
she is as new that saying is new york
through and through you can actually and
probably at times must be tough to be
here because when she walks she's the
type of person
she's walking through the streets i
would say a hundred times a day people
are yelling yolanda vega yeah but also
she can't fault it because it also is i
mean that's what gave her i wonder if
she's like like if she's making money
because
she's the person to draw the knife did
she get a cut of this yeah i mean i i
know i hope she did but like we googled
this yolanda vega we didn't see we did
we did we did and this is going to come
out in another episode but we looked her
up and i think cuban gymnasts by the way
oh yolanda vega on cameo oh well that
makes total sense that makes total sense
if she's on cameo because she's got to
take lunch everybody wants to hear
you should pay five g's to get a yolanda
vega
from one to
149.76 seconds
while standing straight on his father's
shoulders what was the point of that it
is the kid is four years old
he holds the record for counting to a
hundred does he have to stand on his
father's shoulders though
i mean right now we're gonna break his
record right now to show this kid what's
up this kid is about four years old he's
balancing his body on his on his pop
shoulders
i'll wreck this kid
[Music]
fastest time to count from 1 to 100
while standing straight on someone's
shoulders that's what it is let's break
his record right now let's do it right
now right now can you support me can i
support you we'll break his record right
now we'll email him right now we'll have
everybody tweet at him because i'm gonna
shatter it also how about what if i sit
on your shoulders yeah just sit on my
shoulders right now and count to 100 as
long as we time and it's over 49 seconds
we're shattering this kid's recording
everybody right now let's do it all
right it
we're not even gonna practice
don't even don't even practice but
listen to me don't screw this up no we
can't because
just just make sure your addiction is
good you know don't don't don't don't
don't cheat words because i don't want
to be called i don't want to be you're
doing it or i'm doing it oh i thought
you were doing it because you're
standing on my shoulders
okay i'll do it i'm going to time you
though okay all right
and i'll do it in the indian accent as
well what's this gentleman's name
because i want to tell him right now
it's about to get shattered
now you're going to say 21 you're going
to say every every word
and you've got to beat one to 100 you've
got to be 49.76 seconds ready this kid
doesn't know what's his skin's water yes
i'm when i hit start ready okay one
two three go one two three four five six
seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30
31 32 33 34 35 36 37 38 39 40 41 42 43
44 45 46 47 48 49 50 51 52 53 54 55 36
87 38 59 60 61 62 63 64 566 67 68 69 70
71 72 73 74 75 76 77 78 79 80 81 82 83
84 85 86 87 88 89 90 91 82 93 94 96 97
98 99
95. oh 91 92 93 94 95 96 97 98 99 100.
suck it to cash
45-19
you beat him by two seconds and i
skipped 95 and i i t bagged you and i
just farted
he's been walking around on his high
horse for too long that's what it is
name one podcast that does guinness book
world records like we do it guinness if
you're watching i'm legit i nailed that
nailed that you see that and that my
kids is how you take a bad day on the
calorie fitness pal app and you burn off
some cows last minute that's it
i legit out of breath how about this do
i have covered
they say one of the symptoms that people
don't really know a lot is that you uh
you get out of breath can do andre uh
you holy smokes we did it and i missed
enough and you must imagine if you
didn't flub you you would have really
what did i miss again i just 95. i think
you said i think you missed 95.
it's harder than you think i know we
could play it back but you did i that's
why i didn't want i didn't want to i
didn't want to get like disqualified
from from the beginning listen even with
the flub i mean i i 15 seconds i shaved
off the kid yeah no no he did it in 47
no
i mean
what was his 49.76
so you beat him by force handily
4.8 seconds and i think i i think my
technique wasn't good because i was
going 49.
uh what is his name i want to get it
right it was it dake
i can't read that sorry
[Music]
and his family just to let them know
that we're in business some some animal
poop yeah or serotonin saratoga peanut
butter saratoga peanut butter yeah
yeah the kid's a cute kid he did it and
you know by the way he only did it
november 2000 uh 2020. wow so this isn't
he's still that age and this isn't old
you you shattered a record really really
different record and it's
yeah well hold on here we go the fastest
time to type the alphabet is what
to type the alphabet is 3.3 seconds that
one i can't even i mean yeah
oh yeah that's crazy i don't even
understand so just going like a b c d e
g as in
yeah i don't know wow that felt good
that felt nice to go to council came in
here just you know you
and you left here a world record holder
i left your world record holder and that
felt good and i did the whole thing no
i'm sorry
and yeah and right on the back of your
neck teabagged yeah i'm sorry about that
but you know there's nothing we could
really do no but i will tell you like i
was getting i was like i knew i don't
know if you knew this but i was trying
to do a little bit of like projection
and you were at one point you were i
mean you were gonna make you this kid
would have should crawl into a
he should dig a hole and crawl into it
like a goddamn ostrich because he should
be embarrassed yeah no because you were
about to if you didn't flub you would
have had it at like 30 something the
flub is one of those things where it's
like i kind of felt like i was gonna
shatter the record and i just got like
so nervous and it was kind of like my
own like hang-ups about myself like i
think i intentionally with it because i
have a fear of success i think i did
that on purpose and i flipped on purpose
i noticed one thing you were doing but i
couldn't stop you because you can't stop
someone in motion right but you were
doing like a little fun thing at the end
of each uh at the end
59.60 right but that is costing you
valuable half a second it is because i
just thought when we're getting into a
new 10 you know yeah like i want to
sound off right right right so
yeah i uh i i felt good yet so i now i
mean if the guinness book of world
records doesn't i mean they have to give
me give us something it's literally it's
real this is
recorded i think they have to have a rep
present and i will tell you this right
now
we should we should we should get on the
podcast we should get a rep down here we
should break that record 100 i'll do
that register for an account receive an
email i i did hear though that the
guinness book of world records is really
like um
you know like you pay them
for them to come record your record you
know so it's not like right i don't know
if it's independent they i think they
the people that are in it have to pay to
be in it
is that right so it's really not that
big of a deal but honestly patreon
seriously if we want if we want to
shadow this record that go right to the
patreon i'm down to do that dude are we
making a running list of what what will
be on the patreon
all right the kid pimp writes it down
okay because i don't remember do you
think there's a record for longest
podcast
they're happy oh i bet you there's a
stand-up
yeah i went and saw that guy do that
it was happening when i was at like it
was like jfl or something somebody was
doing it and we passed by and looked at
it watched mike russell
did a 36-hour non-stop podcast in 2016.
that is i mean i don't even i mean
do we do try to break that what could
you possibly even be talking about how
how how do you do it
oh 80 hours
i was in nashville it was in nashville
yeah i was there for the wild west
comedy festival right and you saw it
happening well oh no it was the longest
show they asked us to be part of it
that's what it was
man i wonder if i was i can't remember i
know that sounds wild but i did so many
spots that week no it was five it was
six years ago i did so many spots that
week and i know people like i might do
it and i i don't remember if i did it or
if i just went and watched
i don't remember i guess i would be on
there if they they wrote it i would be
honest i'm a fan of even in any form of
entertainment hour hour and a half tops
you get in you get out that's what i
think people like the most i'm not but
you but you know you're different than
me you can sit and really enjoy
something i've been to shows with you
the magic show we went to where it's two
hours and you're invested and you you're
a guy who's in the moment a lot i'm a
guy who i can't really stay focused for
that long on anything but you're you're
do you meditate if it's good uh i nah i
i mean i use the headspace app
right sponsor sponsor
uh once we get the ad read yeah we're
gonna do it that's right oh we haven't
done that yet
oh cut it out okay
oh well no no keep it no they're they're
sponsored for us still oh god bless them
uh yeah no i i i did it for a while
meditation but i don't do it anymore but
i will tell you if the show is good i i
like it i'll stay i mean i should yeah
sometimes
i make choices and i'm like this isn't
helping uh you know people's perception
of my sexuality now i recently bought an
outfit okay you ever buy an alpha that
you think might look good in the store
okay and you're like or even in the
store you're like this is either i was
gonna say fierce but right this is
either an amazing outfit or it's really
ugly okay and i'm either going to put it
on and it's going to respond to me and
people will love it or i'm going to put
it on and it's going to be terrible you
ever buy clothes and be like i don't
know if this is ugly or amazing right
i bought an outfit recently right and
i've it was like two years like a year
or two ago and i've never worn it yet
because as i got home i'm like i
appreciate everything this outfit brings
to the table right it's fun it's funny
it's colorful and it is it's i've never
seen anything like it but if i put this
on
i am going to look like an aging gay
gumball
an agent queen yes
do you favor can you in
if i got up and put this outfit on and
walked back out can we edit it so people
aren't waiting for me to change
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna put an
outfit on for you put it on
i'm gonna you're gonna see it for the
first time when i walk back out of the
room perfect is that okay i love it okay
all right yo
i'm going to start talking
no i'm going to say i have my eyes
closed and i want the fr let me know
when we're ready to go
okay i have my eyes closed right now
because i genuinely want to be surprised
by the first time that sal comes out in
this outfit
and sal you tell me what you're already
settled and i will open my eyes and take
a look
go ahead walk in
this is sal's outfit that he said he
doesn't know if you look like an agent
gumball and if is this outfit gay i have
my eyes closed i am not looking
i will look when he sits down in his
comfortable position
and is ready to speak and just let me
know when i can open my eyes and take a
look
i mean not only do you look gay
yeah get the mic not only does it first
of all i think it's awesome yeah but it
looks gay and it also looks like you
have special needs
it looks like you're the rare combo of a
special needs gay man
okay i was in a store it was like it was
a really nice streetwear store and this
is bold but it's got wrestlers on it and
it's a summertime sweat outfit and it's
shorts and you know it's cut on the
bottom and it's got your wrestling you
know it's got everybody from you could
see
yeah it's got
everybody warrior yeah bret hart and i'm
like this is an amazing matching outfit
i'm going to be the hit of a party in
this thing yeah roll up it looks
comfortable too
it's got you know it's like this local
brand from brooklyn and i mind you look
tank's still on right but actually
that's a little secret little life hack
for you i don't take tags with my
clothes i think we talked about this
never
uh
i usually what do you mean yeah i i
don't take takes off my cause i usually
pull the tag off my clothes after about
three months
yeah
what's the reason uh because i uh don't
want to have buyer's remorse and i want
to make sure that i really am um i
really am okay with with the garment and
i want the option to so what i do
usually is i i do have the gun where i i
could re re put like the tags back on
yeah that's how you know you bought it
on ebay okay so that i could always
bring something so you'll wash clothes
with the tags on
no usually it's like um a jacket or a
sweatshirt or a hoodie but where do you
hunt do you so you just hide your pants
that that thing that's like sewn into
the the back of it on because you know
you could always put it back on you got
me like a loose hanging tag like this
especially if it's in the inside of a
shirt just put on the inside i just put
it on the inside so if we go downstairs
in my closet right now you will see
dozens of things so you're someone who
literally who literally
will have to sometimes stop the podcast
to readjust the corner of a pillow but
can walk around all day with a tag on
your back that's correct yes you know i
just that's insane nobody because i just
want to be like they're not going to get
me yeah you know you know what if i wear
this here twice and all of a sudden it
starts to fray or pill
or oh
but how do you know i'll take it back
what if i don't wear it for a while and
i put it on it's snug or if i buy it
it's snug and i'm hoping to lose weight
and i don't then i can't use it or what
if you buy it what if you buy and you
accidentally drop some saratoga peanut
butter on it maybe and it's
that's a family-run business and that's
not a sponsor there's a lot of flavors
and hopefully they make a flavor with us
one day yeah
um it's interesting by the way i i you
know i came out obviously he was joking
around i actually like that and be would
be willing to say if you don't want it
i'll take it is that right hundred
percent i think i take that right now
really i take it oh see i and you know
what it is over the summer i had the
outfit and uh i was always like i'm
gonna i'm gonna wear this to an event
this summer a barbecue a friend's house
and every time i put it on i would take
it right back off because i said who do
i think i am to wear that to where i
can't pull this off i can't pull this
off and that's the first sign that you
can't that's because if you don't
believe it yeah you're not gonna do it
you can't let this weigh you right now
this is wearing me i have to wear it do
you remember do you remember i think
this was last year when we went into we
were performing and you you and i were
working together in cleveland and i went
into that thrift store or or cool
one-off store in cleveland and i bought
that sweatshirt that had all different
wrappers on it and different colors
and all that 100
same scenario
i would put i put it on two or three
times got to the front door walked right
back in took it off put something else
on i know it's nice
you have to be kind of a bold [ __ ]
yeah to walk out with stuff like that
yeah this is again i i bought this in
the same type of store it was one of
those fashion one-off
fashion stores uh shout out to them uh
yeah shout out that store in cleveland i
it took about an hour and a half for
them to package the sweatshirt do you
remember that
nice guy but you bought one sweatshirt
it took 40 minutes but do you remember
also they were closed but then they let
us come in yeah and they were they were
filming a video or something something
crazy you can make anything you can made
any you can made any animal with any
other animal but i know this is i know i
know really our dna the thing is with
dna
is is what's the thing with dna
first of all shallow cricket and helix
those are the guys that made they
discovered dna shadow quick in here okay
a zonkey they call it
i would have called it a d bruh deborah
a deborah a jaglion i would have called
it looks like that looks straight up
demonic look at the it looks like it's
got all different parts of animals just
glued to it it looks like a franken
sheep it looks like a stuffed animal
that someone propped up i would go if
that was my animal i would go beep beep
who got the keys to the geese male false
kill aware plus a female bottlenose
dolphin a wolf and i stand corrected
that's the best one that was like don't
worry we'll get you a wall because but
calling it a dale would be funny
this is the jewelry box i've had since i
was born it looks like you it looks like
you've stolen off black beard chip or
something this was like this was like a
style when i was younger and this was my
treasure i guess this was my mom's or
someone before her in my family and i
just always thought it was like for me
it's very sentimental it's a nice piece
it's it's it's it's the weirdest thing
in the world it's a nice piece it's a
nice piece and i like that your jewelry
chest has chains on the side of it look
at this yeah look at that
but i mean i mean there's
pictures of me as
it's three weeks old with this on my
mom's bureau like this thing so it means
a lot it actually looks even though it's
from the you know i would assume 70s it
looks kind of modern and new and cool
like if you told me like if you look at
me
no dude if you look like if you said hey
i just bought this yesterday at west elm
i'd say oh yeah oh okay you know what i
mean because it's so it's so old it went
vintage yeah it is
i mean it's without a doubt 50 50 years
old or something like that i didn't
touch this okay so i'm gonna take you
through some of the jewels i wore
you're gonna make fun of you oh wow this
is my first ever earring
what yeah i got my ear pierced after the
junior prom and this is your first and
sal's first ever wow this is an old
school freaking hero yeah right and then
this this is i can't believe you you
didn't lose the back
i would always lose back to then i'd
have to take a pencil eraser and put her
pencil how many of my earrings when i
was a kid i would go through my ear and
then the background was a pencil eraser
yeah everybody has that hack no dude
yeah you would lose you would always
because the backs were so easy to lose
right then you'd have to take the pencil
eraser off your pencil and that would be
your currency
yeah all right ready this i was wearing
at my communion it's a pinky ring
[Music]
it's a look at that look at that ring
can you get in there look look at that
ring it's got a little diamond chip on
it that was my first that was my first
jewel ever and it was a pinky the fact
that you still have this is it wild
right is it wild goes into the boat
you're a serial
ever killer chain let's see if it fits
it's probably like turning black it's
probably not real i don't even know this
is your classic when they say is it
turning green that's how you know it's
fake and this is at the top this is
green green green is it really yeah wow
these are the four pendants i used to
switch so this okay
this is the jesus christ this is a this
is a podcast with two straight men going
through one of that man's jewelry box
collection this is jesus christ on the
cross that's his head that used to oh my
god this is a decapitated golden jesus
he has on the the crown of thorns and
everything this is literally chal used
to walk around with jesus's head on his
chest yeah look at that
that was used to i used to wear that
around it when i made my communion i had
that look at that
yeah jesus's head looking out disgusting
my fingernails i bite my nails i have
anxiety this one is an italian thing you
ever get the horn
yes but what is the significance of the
horn again supposed to ward off evil
spirits right yeah it makes a lot of
sense it looks like a woman's leg of
course you had to have the yankee symbol
of course yeah this even i had the
yankee symbol you had that now look at
this one i started doing this before
anybody else anybody in hip-hop kesha
anybody in eighth grade i'll put on the
patreon i have a picture of the eighth
grade graduation sheet cake and they
wrote every single name of every person
on the in on the in the class on the
cake and there was two sales and they
wrote my name sal with a dollar sign
for all of seventh and eighth grade
whenever i signed my name at the top of
a test or anything i wrote my name sal
with the dollar sign
a teacher ever say you can't do that
anymore nobody else they completely let
me do it sal with a dollar sign look at
that
dude
dude i used to do that can you believe
that and they they just accepted the
school used to write my name as a dollar
sign really yes what a very progressive
cool school yeah look at this would you
ever see me in this thing that's when i
got a little older this is the thing
this is the thing that i feel like i got
you in here right now what is this a
bracelet bracelet oh my god you put it
on my neck i was like what is the little
baby neck sound look at that that's i
don't know what i was doing here this
was 20 years ago then in college i moved
to this type of jewelry remember this
stuff the cheap nonsense that's like yes
you remember but this is like this every
time i see somebody wearing this it
looks like like you're like you're a
cannibal it looks like i'm in like uh it
looks like i'm in white snake yeah you
know like yeah but like this kind of
thing i feel like
okay
what was i thinking
what was i thinking i was into like i
was into like like heavy metal and like
i feel like this is yeah but glamorous i
have this almost exact cross tattooed on
my back
now did you seriously do you ever wear
the shark tooth stuff
like that like the like the thing no no
but here's my most embarrassing thing
let's see it my most embarrassing thing
uh so i started wearing silver jewelry
and this type of jewelry right in
college and i wore i walked around
with these rings on at all times let's
see him you this is so bad dude let's
see him
wow
look at these
first of all
they have one of these is is actually
the emblem that's used on the flag of
the nation of turkey that's what i swear
to god yeah that half moon that is the
symbol of the flag of the nation of
turkey so sal was walking around with
full uh you know stars and then this one
here we go here's this one it has
dolphins on it
this is just dolphins swimming around
his face not even me i'm like what were
you doing and then last but not least i
mean this is just stars the sun this
looks like hieroglyphics yeah
hieroglyphics i walked around with those
on my fingers like
18. like i would go down the shore and
they'd be like at the beach at the
boardwalk you'd buy like silver jewelry
right and it was the same type of vibe
it was always like ah the sun
but dead serious
but dead seriously like you thought like
you'd walk up to warren like what's up
can i get your number with frick with
sunrise
with sun
never mind that this one has stars sun
and moon right which is terrible right
but the dolphins right
the dolphins just sound like it's like i
just don't like sebastian
he would go the dolphin rings aren't you
embarrassed
yeah you're wearing the ring wearing the
rings that's insane dude but for me the
best part of the whole thing is your
treasure box yeah what's gonna now yeah
the treasure box you think you'll keep
that for another 50 years i'll keep that
forever i really like this do you have
anything do you own any possessions that
you haven't that weren't from when you
were born no that's nothing i don't know
which ideas possession you have the
oldest possession i have i have things
from the day i was born
the only thing my mother has my mother
has a hair from the day i was born uh
she has my hair which is weird it's so
weird my mother is a weirdo she took
your hair off yeah she has human baby
hair in um
but but but when you just came out of
the when you just were born or from like
one of the first or maybe your first
haircut maybe my she has hair from when
i was haircut okay okay okay i didn't
like take it off you when you came dude
here's what an idiot i am and i wish i
was better at keeping things and and
keepsakes and all that my father on the
day i was born wrote this beautiful
handwritten letter marked august 26 1984
beautifully hammering just a po like not
a poem like just like how much he loves
me and how much i've changed his life
and actually going over the events that
were going on in his life at that time
what he wanted to overcome the things
that he wanted to help with my mother
folded it up kept it in pristine
condition in a little envelope for 25
years
gave it to me the day i graduated
graduate school because he said i wanted
to give this to you the day you became a
man because he said i feel like i really
became a man when i became your father
he said and now you got and graduated to
graduate school and got your doctorate
degree he was like you became a man
today in my eyes and i want to give you
this letter he gave me that letter on
the car ride home i lost it
you don't have that letter i don't have
that letter oh my god you're what are
you crazy i almost cried just now i read
it cried in the car and i put it in then
into my pocket like an idiot and when i
opened the door or when i must have it
must have fallen out of my pocket at
some point but i'm talking about a
25-year keepsake i lost in the first
hour of having it that's
let's also not gloss over the fact that
that is the most
non-christian stephanos father thing
that he's ever done from everything we
know about him yes that's like the the
polar opposite yeah that was like one of
the most
i actually have a story that kind of
reminds me of this that's unbelievable
he did and he lost that i lost it i have
the stuffed animals from the day i was
born okay i have the outfit that i came
home from the hospital downstairs i have
like the yeah that sack they put me in
right like once again let's write things
down about sal and then things about a
notable serial killer and you tell us we
have to make that game
so i had told the girlfriend of of my
friend was like i'm gonna go for the
kiss on the roller coaster she's like
good she's like she wants to kiss you
like do it so we're in
i we're going up the thing we're holding
each other i'm like this is going to be
right moving for the kiss we go down we
go down while we're going down i just
thought down it would be the perfect
time just because i'm so nervous you
can't even you chip both teeth i go in
to kiss her as her head is coming at her
as her i go in to kiss her as her head
is slamming into
me
on it hits the side of my face she
breaks her nose on the roller coaster oh
yes full broken nose gushing no
sal i swear gushing blood at we have
holy [ __ ] 80 of the roller coaster ride
left to go there's blood flying on my
face
when we got back we're covered in blood
and it's so funny because like the the
guy running the ride six-year-old guy he
goes you guys must have had a good time
i never got to kiss her her nose was
swollen i felt like an idiot the whole
time she broke up with me like three
days later wow i think yoga made me fall
look at this this is just me taking
three steps
oh my god you hit the pavement i know
and then look i'm just
i'm just start talking to myself but
don't you pick up something you tripped
over and say it out loud yeah
oh that's why it was a piece of my
daughter's bike
no yeah
my
are you talking to yourself right now
for real or are you knowing that this
audio and you're gonna be laughing at
this so no the who i'm actually talking
to or was there someone to watch you
from my neighbor was across the street
sitting on her stoop and she saw the
entire
thing
and then we had to walk to the bus stop
to pick up our kids like it didn't
happen she was like are you okay i was
like yeah i was like i was like just my
wrist starts and then she didn't talk
about it for like the rest of the day
but then she went to go get her nails
done with jasmine and that's all they
talked about they watched this video
like a hundred times and she was saying
she was like i was gonna piss myself
with laughter but i genuinely thought he
got hurt yeah it wasn't a graceful fall
you have to go haagen-dazs yeah
everybody knows that everybody knows
that but do you think bryce thinks
they're even competing
hitler's ice cream that's right
it is
is that was it around during him
if you're listening and you we know that
you are uh
we we don't know that this is
speculation we're going to find out
right speculation but we will put you on
blast if it's true i got news for you i
got i got about i got about a quarter of
a lot of vodka in uh in this christmas
cheetos handmade vodka and i got and i'm
on low sleep so i apologize if i'm
coming out
what do we got oh the fuhrer cake an
apple cake strong with nuts and raisins
had to be baked each day and left out
every night he was also partial to
chocolate biscuits and scones with tea
which he would drink from a nymphenburg
porcelain cup on paper on paper if you
didn't know anything about this like i'd
hang out with this guy
just if you're judging a man by his
treasure
i mean we're having a good time lesson
learned do nev never never judge a man
by his favorite treats never he could be
the worst person ever birthed yeah birth
wars made on living with the fuhrer he
loved midnight cake
linen linens and tea from porcelain
china cups
there you go
okay
well haagen does
yeah let's get back to haagen-dazs but
you know who do you think haagen-dazs
number one competitor is
i mean volkswagen joe derose is going to
die
i mean everybody's doing taste buds now
hi hi what's your name so you have a
good what's your name my name is vanessa
hi vanessa hi vanessa
this is like your shitter's anonymous
stand up
vanessa say hi my name is vanessa and
this is my [ __ ] story yeah and call
yourself yeah and say hashtag on the
ship queen
hi my name is vanessa this is [ __ ] story
hi vanessa [ __ ] queen
hi vanessa
so i was living with my boyfriend at the
time and i had previously clogged his
toilet to the point where his
grandfather
you had previously clogged his toilet
previously clogged this toilet so bad
that his 80 year old grandfather had to
get in there with the snake and like
really rip it out so i was traumatized
fast forward like a month later and i
had to [ __ ] so
and everyone was home and i was had to
cross through the living room to get to
the bathroom and there was no way i was
going to let them know that i was taking
a [ __ ] so
but please tell the 400 000 listeners
yeah
so i took a shoebox in the bathroom
i [ __ ] in the shoe box
put the shoe box in a bag and walked it
outside and put it in the garbage and it
got picked up
i'm so serious
[Applause]
can i can i can i just pitch something
right now can i pitch something right
now stay right there we've never had a
guest on hey babe can she be the first
guest on a base yes
[Applause]
this is vanessa the [ __ ] queen we gotta
talk to her
all hail vanessa the [ __ ] queen
[ __ ] queen
who knew our first guest
babies vanessa who just told us she's
[ __ ] in a shoebox
welcome vanessa
how how you doing honey nice to meet you
still have you mike where's your mind i
got your phone all right
homeless pimp's got the phone hello i
have sit with us by the way i smell a
brewing romance between homeless pimp
and the [ __ ] queen
call me
his reactions are delayed enough i know
he's taking an edible in the back
you can share
what do you think single little little
known fact about homeless people
unfortunately
who cares
he wasn't cool enough to come here so
exactly oh really
oh dump him like a shit-filled shoebox
babe amen
[Applause]
here's okay couple things um you what
i'm confused about
we all heard the story right real quick
i would assume you're from philadelphia
boxes yeah okay congratulations
yep
so you didn't know
but you you still
did the exact same thing
as [ __ ]
you still [ __ ] [ __ ] came out of you in a
room
it's just that you walked it out the
door
instead of down the pipes but until
today no one knew that because there was
no flush there was no flux what about
the smell traipsing through the house
well i did wait a couple minutes you
know and then and i febreze you got it
febreze if you don't febreze and you're
just assassinating you walked out of the
back room in front of a family full of
people with a shoe box smelling like a
meadow
don't you think the febreze is a dead
giveaway it was pumpkin spice for
starters okay now i'm hungry i'm sorry
it's not unusual for me to smell like
pumpkin spice so yes yeah but you walk
in and then when you walk back by the
way where were you going with a bag and
a bot like did they nobody looked at you
and was like yeah where is she going
were you like oh i got new sneakers so i
put the shoe box in it was like a
birthday bag or something and then i was
just like taking out the trash and just
looked it up you were taking out a
shoebox-sized bag of trash i was in your
boyfriend's home yep
and you don't think ex-boyfriend you
don't think that everybody there had a
side conversation that was like did you
smell the abundance of pumpkin spice
when she walked out of the basement if
they did they were nice enough to not
say anything wow was it even halloween
no yeah so they knew you shouldn't have
pumpkin spice all year round
[Laughter]
to do a human function in the proper
place and flush it in front of six
people but you're singing
to the world
what about like how do you know that
like there was an empty where were the
shoes that were in that box they still
were like where the hell is my jordan
shoebox
so it was tom shout out toms um it's a
tom shoebox
they're very into you know biodegradable
and nature stuff so yeah they are big
time so i was kind of giving back to you
i should i could have buried it or
something and thinking back like i wish
i'd done something cooler with it
this [ __ ] is bananas h-e-y-b-a-b-e
this [ __ ] is bananas h-e-y-b-a-d
this [ __ ] in a box
pumpkin spice
did you did you should be okay
what room were you in so i was in the
back bedroom when all this occurred and
i had to walk up a hallway just in the
living room and then right out like the
door off the kitchen was it a spare
bedroom was it his bedroom it was his
bedroom we were living together at the
time okay
get him on the phone
if i had his number i would because he's
a dirtbag
wow says the woman who's [ __ ] in a box
in his room
[Applause]
i love it
let me tell you about this guy he was a
real low down dirty fella what are the
chances she's telling us while she's
[ __ ] and hovering did you hover
how did you do it oh good question how'd
you know you're gonna hit the target
yourself very tastefully okay you know
you put the box on the bed no no no you
don't get to call this that's a very
tasteful way to do it if anybody could
do a taste release the [ __ ] queen thank
you
i just put it on the edge of the bed
like where like the corner oh my god you
didn't put it on the [ __ ] floor what
have you got it on the comforter
wait you you why put it that high
did you sit did your ass touch box i was
thinking it was a hover i was thinking
it was a hover
so you use the edge of the box like a
[ __ ] toilet seat so i don't sit on
toilet seats like at least ever because
it's disgusting yeah um [ __ ] in a
box
sitting in a box is okay vanessa there
is no way you're vaccinated oh god i
know you're not
you you are you should work for the
public health you should you would be
the perfect girl hey guys even i got
vaccinated and i [ __ ] in boxes
you clearly have sat with this story for
years and made it okay in your mind in
your mind
[Applause]
did you ever hear this story ever in
your life you knew this story so this
has been circulating around
for a long time have you ever [ __ ] in a
box
interesting
okay so please go ahead um so i just
hovered over the corner like on the on
the edge
got it done um i
i took an old t-shirt
stop it's very tasteful
it's very tasty
she could have used something like
toilet paper but she didn't i didn't
have she wanted to keep it on the up and
up guys give it up for salvagano's
calves please great cats
and his hairless legs he's like a sphynx
cat
so the t-shirt went in the box as well
so did he does he know you did this oh
yeah oh okay okay he knows so i remember
remember how in the in the first couple
of months of the podcast we sent [ __ ] in
a box to bad friends yes who did we send
vanessa [ __ ] in a box too what podcast
oh my god who do we send it to
tim dillon's podcast
the tim dillon would you would you be
willing to send your [ __ ] to tim dillon
it would be my honor
vanessa
homeless pimp if you don't take this
girl out on a date you're fired
i don't know who
in the world could top that [ __ ] story
you know i don't know if we're gonna
have an hour of [ __ ] stories but after
that just happened i say why not i don't
i don't know forget the show i don't
know who's gonna be a better guest than
her i know we could literally have the
ex-president on what did you think the
family of the boyfriend that you were
living with would think of you if let's
just say you went to the bathroom like a
normal person
why were you so afraid of that
um i don't think i was afraid i was just
so
embarrassed at the time because this
poor 80 year old man had to get on his
knees and like dig for my [ __ ] out of a
toilet and i was trying to spare them i
think oh because of the previous blowout
because of the preaching because you
were so worried about that
you had clogging
well vanessa i then it bears to this
question is that the only time you've
[ __ ] in a box that is the only time i've
ever [ __ ] in a box but i'm there's a bot
[Applause]
and it's vanessa's
i did about two years ago had to
had to go when i was at the beach okay
so we dug a hole
we pooped in the hole and we buried it
up so can i answer a question
do you have a home to live in where do
you live
if you're homeless can you she could
sleep on the couch tonight yeah yeah
yeah
i have a home yes well it doesn't sound
like it
you're [ __ ] in halls
i just live on the edge what do you do
yeah
we know so i work for a company that
manages foreclosed homes for banks so we
kick people out of their houses
oh my god oh my god you are the funniest
person i've ever met
you kick you kick people out of their
homes for a living
i mean they kick themselves out they're
not paying their bills okay i'm sorry
this school of hot knocks from the [ __ ]
queen herself
they kicked themselves i love it
i love that
definitely a republican
not that's good or bad it's just that
that's a republican stance they do kick
themselves out i guess 100
wow well vanessa i mean god bless we got
some new merch ideas yeah
vanessa's box
it's not what you think it is i'll buy
it
give it give it up for vanessa everybody
holy [ __ ] vanessa first hate babe guest
ever was a real doozy
you're the best it was amazing to meet
you i love you i actually love you
i mean what a great beautiful person
beautiful smile
amazing she has everything going for her
except that she's just just shits in
boxes and kicks people out of her house
we can get if she you know if anybody
has a box if she needs to go he's an
a-plus plus
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey